كهد الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب باجتثاث
تنظيم الدوله من على وجه الارض بتعاون مع
الحلفاء مع العالم الاسلامي لكن كيف
الاجابه في خطط وضعتها وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ما زالت تفاصيلها طي الكتمان
غير ان تقارير وتصريحات امريكيه اشارت الى
انها تشمل اجراءات عسكريه ودبلوماسيه
وماليه وانها تستهدف ايضا تنظيم القاعده
وتنظيمات اخرى في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وخارج منطقه الشرق الاوسط تبقى تساؤلات
بشان تعقيدات التعاون مع الحلفاء وما اذا
كانت واشنطن ستدفع بقوه بريه لمواجهه
تنظيم الدوله في معاقله داخل سوريا
والعراق نتابع بدايه هذا التقرير للزميل
محمد
العالمي توصل البيت الابيض بتفاصيل
الاستراتيجيات المقترحه من كبار مساعيه
العسكريين في وزاره الدفاع لمحاربه تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه لكن تفاصيل الخطط
المقترحه بقيت حتى الان في غايه السريه
على خلاف معظم اسرار البيت الابيض في
الاونه
الاخيره وكان الرئيس ترامب وفي اول خطاب
له امام الكونغرس قد اعاد التاكيد على هدف
تدمير التنظيم الذي شكل واحدا من ابرز
تعهداته
[تصفيق]
الانتخابيه كما تعاهدت فقد امرت وزاره
الدفاع بتحضير خطه والتخلص من تنظيم
الدوله هذه العصابه من المتوحشين الخارجين
عن القانون الذين ذبحوا مسلمين ومسيحيين
والرجال والنساء والاطفال من كل المعتقدات
سنعمل مع حلفائنا بمن فيهم حلفائنا في
العالم الاسلامي لمحو هذا العدو الشرير من
كوكب
الارض الجنرال جوزيف دانفورد رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه كان قد اشار الاسبوع
الماضي الى ان الاستراتيجيه المقترحه لن
تقتصر على تنظيم الدوله فحسب بل ستستهدف
ايضا تنظيم القاعده وتنظيمات اخرى في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وخارجها واكد اكبر
مسؤول عسكري في الحكومه الامريكيه ان
الخطه المقترحه ستشمل ايضا جانبا سياسيا
ولن تقتصر على الجبهه
العسكريه وعلى الرغم من شح التفاصيل حول
ما اقترحه العسكريون الامريكيون في واشنطن
يبدو ان الصوره لم تكتمل بعد لدى القاده
العسكريين الميدانيين الذين يريدون تكرار
نجاحه العراق في تحرير الموصل وتطبيقها
على على مدينه الرقا لكنهم لا يملكون جيشا
نظاميا في سوريا على خلاف
العراق مازال امامنا بعض الوقت لدراسه كل
خياراتنا بما فيها طبيعه القوات التي
ستحرر الرقه ولم نستبعد اي خيار وما زلنا
ندرس هذه القضايا ووضع خطتنا بالاشتراك مع
باقي
حلفائنا لكن مراقبين يعتقدون ان حاجه
واشنطن الملحه لدعم الاتراك وحساسيه انقره
من تسليح راض سوريا لن تترك من خيارات
بديله سوى نشر المزيد من القوات البريه
الامريكيه فوق الاراضي
السوريه اعتقد انه من المحتمل ان ينشر
الرئيس ترامب قوات بريه تقليديه في كل من
العراق وسوريا لسببين اولهما كونه قدم
تعهدا سياسيا قويا بتدمير تنظيم الدوله
وثانيا فان وجود قوات تقليديه امريكيه في
سوريا سيخفف من الحاجه للقوات الكرديه
السوريه
ويبدو ان حسابات المعركه المقبله حملت
البيت الابيض على اعاده الحياه الى
تحالفات واشنطن التقليديه وربما كانت ايضا
وراء رفع العراق من قائمه الدول المشموله
بحضر السفر الى الولايات
المتحده انضم الينا من واشنطن كل من
الدكتور محمد الشرقاوي استاذ تسويه
النزاعات الدوليه والسياسات العامه في
جامعه جورج ميسن ودوجلاس اوليفنت المستشار
السابق في شؤون ل القومي نرحب بضيفي
الكريمين نبدا معك سيد اوليفنت يعني رغم
المطالبه بالسريه بعض التسريبات بدات تظهر
احد المسؤولين وهو جيف ديفيس تحديدا
المسؤولين الامريكيين قال بخصوص هذه
الاستراتيجيه بانها خطه تتطور وتتبلور مع
الوقت وليست موضوعه مسبقا وجاهزه للتطبيق
وقال بانها ليست عسكريه وليست خاصه
بالعراق وسوريا فقط ما الذي يعنيه كل ذلك
عم
عمليا كما قال انها خطه قابله
للتطوير والاستمرار يعني انها الشيء نفسه
يتكرر بالنسبه العراق يعني الاستمرار على
الخطه الموجوده من الان والاستمرار في
استعاده الموصل بعد شرق الموصل الان غرب
الموصل الى السياده العراقيه والعمل من
اجل حل سياسي في العراق الاطراف هذا يعني
ان المزيد من الدعم سيذهب الى افغانستان
وعلى وجه الخصوص المزيد من الدعم لليبيا
التي اجبرت الولايات المتحده والمجتمع
الدولي للبحث في اي الفصائل يحتاج الى دعم
لمحاربه داعش في ليبيا في سوريا المشكله
الاساسيه تبقى كما هي لا توجد خيارات جيده
الاتراك
والاكراد لا يقبلان بعضهما البعض وهناك
خبرات سيئه سابقه عندما نحاول ان نعمل مع
القوات المتمرده نفع لكن لم ينفع الولايات
المتحده فالسؤال حول سوريا يبقى قائما حول
ما ينبغي عمله دكتور محمد اذا هي خطه
متحركه ومتغيره لكن اذا ما قرنت بعهد سابق
هو عهد اوباما مع ترامب ما المتوقع هل نحن
امام تغير كامل لقواعد الاشتباك
الاستراتيجي
بخصوص الحرب على تنظيم
الدوله اود ان استعمل عباره ديفيد فرام
المحرر في مجله اتلانتيك اليوم عندما قال
ان الرئيس ترامب قدم الكثير من التعهدات
لحمايه الامن القومي الامريكي لكنه لم
يقدم استراتيجيات واضحه ا ما نسمعه الان
هو مجرد تصور اولي عن ما سيصبح خطه قد
تكون ماليه قد تكون عسكريه الى حد ما
بالتشاور مع المخابرات مع وزاره الماليه
مع وزاره الدفاع ومع وزاره الخارجيه الان
يبدو ان البيت الابيض يميل الى دفع ما كان
يعرف ضمن عهد اوباما بخطه تحطيم
وتدمير داعش
والقاعده خطوه الى الامام بمعنى تضييق
الخناق وترامب بالخصوص يتعهد بالقضاء على
وصول داعش الى مصادر التمويل الى حقول
النفط واستهلاكها وبالتالي هو الان ينظر
ليس فقط الى الرقه والوضع داخل سوريا ايضا
الى العراق وينبغي ان ننتبه ايضا الى ما
سيحدث في اليمن وفي ليبيا اود ان اذكر
بتصريح للجنرال دانفورد الاسبوع الماضي في
مععد بركز عندما قال ان الخطه ستشمل ايضا
نشر قوات بريه في العراق لضمان الاستقرار
بعد القضاء على داعش والسيطره على الرقه
فيبدو ان هناك توجه الى المزيج بين قوات
خاصه والاستعانه بال بشمر وقوات اخرى
وينبغي ان ننتظر بعد الايام لتتضح قضيه
اي الاسلاميه والعربيه هذه النقطه بالفعل
الدول الاقليميه عندما يتحدث ترامب عن
اشراك الحلفاء من يقصد بدايه من هؤلاء ما
حدود اشراكهم ما الدور المطلوب منهم هل
سيكون تمويلي فقط ام على الارض ايضا
عسكريا نود ان نفهم بخصوص هذه
النقطه لحد الان لم يحدد البيت الابيض
اسماء هذه الدول سواء العربيه او
الاسلاميه في الشرق الاوسط لكن هناك ت لا
لا هناك تصريح لشخص يسمى سيباستيان جوركا
وهو مساعد للرئيس ترامب وهو الذي كان محرر
شؤون الامن القومي في موقع برانت بارت
الذي تزعمه ستيف بانن حتى وقت ق هذا الشخص
قال ان فكره التحالف تتركز اساسا على دوله
دتين عربيتين هما الاردن ومصر وينبغي ان
نبدا من هذه النقطه الان بمعنى ان مشروع
التحالف يبدا من هاتين الدولتين وربما
سيشمل ت غريب ما تذكر دكتور محمد لان
تحليلات كثيره تحدثت عن تركيا وعن المملكه
العربيه السعوديه دعني اتحول السيد
اوليفانت بخصوص هاتين النقطتين تركيا
المطلوب منها هناك من يتحدث ربما عن
تعقيدات ذكرتها ان تركيا وهي الحليف في
النيتو مطلوب منها دور في محاربه تنظيم
الدوله لكن هناك تعقيدات على الارض وهو
البعد الاخر عدائها للاكراد الذين تدعمهم
واشنطن كيف يمكن بالفعل لاداره ترامب ان
توازن بين هاتين المسالتين
بكل دقه
وتان هاتين المجموعتان ينبغي الاجراء
التوازن دقيق بينهما واضح ان لا احد من
الطرفين يحب الاخر الولايات المتحده تشعر
بشيء من الولاء تجاه الاكراد ومن جهه اخرى
تركيا حليف منذ فتره طويله ايضا لكن تركيا
قبل الانقلاب الفاشل هي غير تركيا بعدها
لذلك لا ندري هل ان سوف نذهب ابعد شوط مما
نذهب اليه الان ام لا في م ابعد من ذلك
اود ان افصل معك في جزئيه العراق ايضا
العراق الوضع ربما فيه بعض التعقيد
والالتباس ايضا يتشارك بالفعل القوات
الحكوميه العراقيه تحديدا تتشارك مع
الولايات المتحده في محاربه تنظيم الدوله
لكن هذه القوات الحكوميه تشاركها ميليشيا
هي بالاساس تقدم الولاء لايران التي نعرف
جميعا موقف اداره ترامب منها هذه الجزئيه
ايضا كيف ستؤثر على المخططات على الارض
ايضا الوضع في
العراق ابسط كثيرا مما
تصورون المؤسسات العسكريه الان تخضع الى
درجه ما من السيطره ربما ليس سيطره كامله
للحكومه الجنرال تاونز القاض الامريكي في
العراق قال لا مشكله مع الميليشيات منذ ان
وصل لعراق قبل اذا لديك
الميليشيات والجيش عفوا والشمر كلهم
يتجهون نحو الموصل تقريبا نصف الموصل تم
تحريرها من داعش اذا اقتربنا من النهايه
لكن التسويه السياسيه بعد ذلك هي التي
عليها الانظار وايضا اهميه زياره وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الى بغداد في الاسبوع
الماضي تظهر بان الناس بداوا يفهمون بانك
اذا ما اردت تصدي للنفوذ الايراني في
العراق عليك ان تذهب الى العراق وتظهر
امامهم انك صديق لكم ومستعد لدفع التاثير
الايراني الى الوراء دكتور محمد يعني في
الواقع العديد من النقاط ونحن نحاول تلمس
ملامح هذه الاستراتيجيه وكما يبدو ترامب
من خلال شخصيته ومن خلال ما تسرب بانه
ربما يرتكز على عنصر المفاجاه والتكتم كما
قال لانجاح هذه الاستراتيجيه او ملامح ما
يبدو التحضير له روسيا فاعل اخر سياسيا
لكن عسكريا ايضا في سوريا ما محددات
التعامل معها هل نحن امام ربما اعاده
تنسيق عسكري مع الروس بخصوص روسيا كيف
يمكن ان يكون شكله مع تعقد وتعقيد العلاقه
اصلا بين الامريكيين
والروس يبدو ان التقارب الروسي الامريكي
في عهد ترامب هو الوجه الاخر لعمله
التعامل مع معضله الارهاب وداعش وبقيه
الجماعات
الراديكاليه يبدو ان ترامب في هذه المرحله
يعتقد ان لديه ورقه استراتيجيه يلعبها على
المستوى الخارجي وايضا على المستوى
الداخلي بمعنى طمانه الراي العام الامريكي
خاصه ان التعاون مع موسكو بالتحديد في
مكافحه ما يسميه بالارهاب الاسلامي
المتطرف داخل سوريا والعراق وثم اليمن
وفيما بعد ليبيا هذا تبرير منطقي يوسع من
شعبيته وايضا يخفض من اوجه الانتقادات او
على الاقل المخاوف داخل الكونجرس فيبدو ان
هناك ورقه الان ستستغل اكثر من مره ويبدو
ايضا انه يريد ان يظهر بانه هو
فعلا يعني يطبق ما وعبد به بانه هو الذي
يحمي حمى الامن القومي الامريكي داخليا وا
ايضا خارجيا فاعتقد هناك استثمار سياسي
واستثمار ايضا على الصعيد الخارجي في
تقريب الكرملين من هذه المغامره لكن يبقى
الان الى اي حد ستستطيع موسكو وواشنطن
المضيه قدما في هذه المغامره العسكريه
والى اي حد سوف توافق عليها الحكومات
الاقليميه بمعنى هل يتوقف الاستثمار عند
الدور الروسي ام ربما سيرغب او يحفز بعض
الادوار العربيه في المنطقه بدايه
من السعوديه دول الخليج ومرورا بتركيا
وربما حتى بعض الدول الاخرى في المنطقه ا
الان ما المتوقع رغم انه من الصعب اثبتت
الايام التوقع بخصوص اي قرارات يمكن ان
تتخذها اداره ترامب وخاصه مع الحديث عن
ضروره التكتم وعنصر المفاجا لاحراز اي
تقدم لكن ما المتوقع من خلال قراءه
للتصريحات والاوضاع على الارض بخصوص هذا
الدور العس عسكريه الذي يمكن ان تقدم عليه
الولايات المتحده في محاربه تنظيم الدوله
تحديدا في سوريا ه نتوقع مثلا ان نصحو
يوما على قوات بريه امريكيه على الارض في
محاربه تنظيم الدوله ام انه سيتم الاكتفاء
كما اداره اوباما باداره او قياده من
الخلف سياسه ترامب ينطبق عليها القول
الماثور اذا كنت اذا كان كل ما تملك هو
مطرقه فان العالم يبدو بمثابه مسمار ترامب
ليس متمرسا في العمل الدبلوماسي هو مؤمن
بالمطرقه وباستخدام القوه هو احد مكرس ما
يعرف بالريل بوليتيك فلا نستغرب انه يريد
ان يتمسك بقضيه العنصر المفاجاه ويبدو
الان ان تصعيد ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع
بحوالي 10% هذا ايضا امر اخر لانه يريد ان
يعتمد على تكنولوجيا جد متفوقه ويريد ان
يباغت العدو فيبدو الان ان معاركه في
الخارج تبدا من داعش باستخدام كل الوسائل
سواء كانت قوات فرد يعني على الارض او
يعني تعزيز العمليات الجويه التي بدات منذ
سبتمبر هذا الشق العسكري دكتور محمد في
سؤال اخير للسيد اوليفانت
من خلال التسريبات هذه الاستراتيجيه او
الخطه او ما يفكر فيه على مستوى اداره
ترامب ليس عسكريا قيل بانه يمكن ان يكون
سياسيا اي شكل لتدخل
سياسي في محاربه بالتنظيم الدوله
باعتقادك كما سبقت الاشاره اليه من قبل
سوف تحاول امريكا اشراك الشركا اكثر من ذي
قبل فنحن نعلم ان اي تسويه للشرق
الاوسط تتطلب اجراء
اشراك اللاعبين الكبار الفاعلين الكبار
مثل السعوديه والايرانيين والاسرائيليين
وغيرهم رغم ان الايرانيين يتم احتوائهم
بشكل ما ربما بالامكان تحقيق تقدم بشان
ليبيا من الواضح
ان الوضع في ليبيا يحتاج الى مقاربه جديده
في ضوء وضع الحكومه وصراعها ضد داعش طبعا
يبقى هناك شيء ما هو متاح من خيارات محدود
وايضا ربما عليه على الاداره الامريكيه ان
تقبل المزيد من الضح
ير من قوا الاشتباك لست متاكدا هذا سيحقق
النتيجه اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيد دوجلاس
اوليفنت المستشار السابق في شؤون الامن
القومي كما نشكر جزيل الشكر الدكتور محمد
شرقاوي استاذ تسويه النزاعات الدوليه
والسياسات العامه في جامعه جورج ميسن
كنتما معنا من
واشنطن ما اسباب ودلالات منع وكيل الامين
العام للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه من
دخول تعز والى اين وصلت الاوضاع الانسانيه
في هذه المدينه وفي عموم اليمن تساؤلات
يبحث حسن جمول عن اجابه لها في الملف
الثاني من الحصد